[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who shows
his boner to girls in his room
and leaves them more disappointed than
the evan peters reveal
one division has now concluded but
there's still a lot of questions up in
the air
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down agatha's plan
ralph what happened with the doctor
strange cameo and a lot more
obviously we don't want to ruin the show
so if you haven't seen it click off now
if you don't want any spoilers
if you enjoy the video and crap puns in
general then please click the thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into your questions
okay so even after finishing the series
i've seen a lot of people confused over
what agatha's plan was
the villain s made one of the biggest
bangers of the 20s so far
and catherine han was spellbinding in
every moment
many myself included believe that it
would be revealed that agatha's husband
ralph had become trapped somewhere
and similar to wonder she was trying to
find a way to bring him back
with a massive dong however this wasn't
the case
and it's left people senor scratching
their head over exactly what she was
after
what the hell was it well calm down and
i'll tell you
and in order to discuss this we have to
go back to 1693
namely agatha's trial during this we
learned that she had been dabbling in
powers above her station
and after being sentenced she absorbed
the life force of her coven
agatha was clearly obsessed with power
from a young age
and when wanda appeared on the scene she
likely started to watch over her
agatha revealed to wander that she had
been following her for a while
and she likely tracked her to west view
which is where she saw what she was
doing in the hex first hand
this is why she swoops in wearing her
normal clothes and joins the sitcom
alongside that absolute banger now a big
question over the series
was who had hypnotized the police to
ignore west view
though initially suspected to be wonder
because this was outside the hex
we now know that agatha was probably the
one behind it
this sort of sets up her plan which was
to keep everyone on the outside
oblivious to what was going on
so that she could remain in the hex with
wonder until she was finally drained
similar the boy in the yo magic
commercial agatha also wanted to learn
how wonder was able to accomplish what
she did
and therefore the longer she kept her in
there the better
now the best way to make her remain in
the hex was to have her gain emotional
attachments to those inside it
after watching her create vision she
subliminally hinted to her that she
should have kids
as this would make her remain behind for
their children
when wanda started to question things
she took a local of west view
and then had them masquerade as her
deceased brother in order to keep her
static
knowing that moniker and vision were
also starting to uncover the truth
she found ways to separate them from the
character and started to sink her
clothes in more and more
agatha eventually planned to reveal
herself when wonder was isolated
and this is why she put vision as far
away as she could
and also kidnapped her kids this would
make wanda eventually attack her so that
she could absorb her power
and become an even more powerful witch
but what happened to agatha after the
events of the season
well when her plan failed wonder left
her trapped in the illusion of being a
nosy neighbor
i'm not sure where she would go now as
we know that ralph lives in her house
but catherine han did state in an
interview with the new york times that
she was still stuck in this persona
this also means that the spell would
remain even after the hex closed
this leaves a lot of things up in the
air for her future and when going over
what was next for the character
han said the following agatha needed to
rest for a hard second
she's been very restless for the moment
so stop with that
she'd be very restless for the moment i
think she's actually okay to just loosen
the corset
and sit and have a muffin and a latte
which is a nice thing to say now hand
stated that marvel were keeping tight
lipped over whether she would return
but the actress said she'd definitely be
up for doing more
the times even asked if she thought
there was a chance of her fitting the
mental roles similar the comics
and here's what she said i felt that
strongly too
at the end of that there was a
possibility that we'd join up
so it does seem like agatha will be
returning
i'm not sure if the people of west view
know she and agnes are one of the same
so maybe she's just gonna sit back and
watch the kevin spoilers show
featuring chevy spoilers now for a lot
of the other questions
i want to go to the fat man beyond
podcast hosted by kevin smith and mark
bernardin
the pair have just had a big interview
with matt shakman the series director
who cleared up a lot of the confusion
he did say that the show was originally
supposed to be 10 episodes long
but they cut them down in order to
streamline the series
it's also been reported that the doctor
strange cameo was supposed to pop up in
this 10th entry
but then it was taken out so the plot
point could appear in his upcoming movie
if you've been following our coverage on
the show then you'll know that i've
often said i thought the series would
end with wonder on her own without
vision
and this would be because it would be
confusing for fans who only watched the
films to go from endgame to doctor
strange in the multiverse
of madness therefore i'm predicting that
strange will just pop up
and pay some lip service to the show in
which he talks about how she's dabbled
in magic
that involves bringing her husband back
to life and creating children
thus when white vision and the kids pop
up down the line
those that haven't seen the show will
just be filled in with this one thing
and assume that after the events of
endgame that's what wonder did
that's just been guessing but my gran
shout out to my gran actually loves
the mcu but she doesn't have disney plus
now they do need to stop marvel maniacs
like her getting lost
so that makes the most sense to me now
shakman also revealed that there was a
big scene that they cut that involved
monica
and the kids sneaking into agatha's
basement in order to steal the darkhold
during this it was revealed that senor
scratchy was actually a demon
and this kind of dived off from a
conversation about everyone being
mephisto
and i don't i don't want to talk about
it i don't want to go down that rabbit
hole again hey
a bit of a pun there anyway i'll play
the clip so you can see what shackman
had to say
i loved the i loved the you know
everything down to like the cicada on
the
curtain that was mephisto everyone was
mephisto the mailman was memphis though
rabbit i was like the rabbit mr
scratchy's got it let me just say
something about
about senor scratchy we did we did have
something more
uh planned for senor scratchy which we
ultimately couldn't do
just because the finale we had so many
different as i said so many different
chess pieces on the
we did have a whole sequence where darcy
monica
ralph meet up with the kids and they're
in agatha's house and they
they think that maybe they should steal
the darkhold um from the basement
because the kids had seen it when they
were down there
being held hostage by agatha and they go
down there to get the book
and they're reaching for the book and
the rabbit hops up in front of the book
and they're like i don't say you're
scratchy he's the best and then like
reach over to pet him and he like hisses
and then this whole american werewolf in
london transformation happens and
the rabbit turns into this big demon
right into her like familiar you know
and uh and then gooney's set piece
ensues with all sorts of fun
as they try to escape from the rabbit
you know but we didn't we we shot
it but didn't finish all the vfx and
stuff for it um and it was
it was a great sequence it was super fun
everyone was great in it
um but we ended up you know moving it
aside because it was a huge sort of
detour
in the middle of everything else that we
had going so yeah so senor scratchy
did have a little bit more left on the
cutting room floor
now in the interview they also went over
some easter eggs and ones that were and
weren't intentional
it actually turns out that the kickass
one wasn't and it was just a happy
accident as for the aerospace engineer
the director revealed that this line was
reworked and messed about with during
shooting
but that they didn't expect the internet
to run with it like they did
what do you mean the aerospace engineers
mephisto i bloody i bloody knew i told
you
now it was always intended to be major
good net and the only reason that
shackman said he didn't come and clear
this up whilst the hype was running wild
is because people would have got their
answers eventually anyway
now another big question is who's jimmy
woo's missing person
in the witness protection program this
is still something that hasn't been
answered
but lend me your ears as we discuss the
two possibilities
now the first is the mailman who says
don't shoot i'm just a messenger
he repeats this throughout the show and
if he was wanted by people for snitching
then it's likely that he would be
worried about getting shot
typically someone is put under witness
protection because they give
information to the police that puts them
in grave danger
mailmen also deliver information so the
ties are there if you're like a reach
and we all know that here at the channel
we reach for the stars
the other possibility is that it's
actually ralph bona
who boner now now this holds a lot of
weight
for a number of reasons firstly we know
that jimmy wu and hayward were both
concerned about this missing person
which is why the latter sent monica to
track him down however
this plot point has dropped quicker than
vision when wanda learns she can get
herself a bad boy
and it never comes back up now the
reason why this could be
is because the pair actually learned
that the missing person
is in west view when he shows up on
wonder's doorstep
it's kind of funny how immediately after
his arrival all the attention switches
to wonder
and it could be because them seeing him
here confirms that he's okay
when we get his true identity it's also
on a weird headshot of himself
now i don't know about you yet but i'm
pretty self-obsessed
i and even i don't have photos of myself
lying around with my name on it
what i do know about though is the
witness protection program
you see i used to be called definition
but after i spoiled avengers end game i
had to go into hiding because mickey
mouse wanted me dead
i was given a cover story and a piece of
paper with my photo and name on it
so that i could learn it and this is
very similar to what we see here
the fact that ralph laughs at his own
name as well likely shows that it isn't
really his
and therefore you can assume that he's
actually the one in hiding
shackman did say that sitcoms do a lot
of meta jokes all the time
and that evan peters was picked to play
pietro for this exact reason
i don't want to be hard on him but it
was a bit of a flop
though i can see things from his
perspective let's be honest if it was
just some random actor
we likely wouldn't have cared about the
character but the fact that it was
peter's
kept us coming back shakman stated that
the x-men
are coming so don't worry and hopefully
we get a ralph bone a disney plus show
coming in 2020. thank you very much
now there are theories that he's
actually still quicksilver and that he
was put in witness protection and given
a new identity because he's from another
earth
and they don't want people asking
questions i'm not getting yanked on that
one anymore though and i have accepted
that this might be the only time we see
him in the mcu
i hope not though now another question
we don't have the answer to is what
happened to the beekeeper
shakman still hasn't clarified this and
i know
this is a your question censored video
but i don't want to leave
any questions out of it as people will
immediately start asking in the comments
why i didn't talk about this
now there are two possibilities with the
most extreme one being that he became
swarm
because we know the hex grants powers to
people if they pass in and out of it
a similar situation to what happened
with monica may have happened to him
we know his name is franklin and in the
comics swarm's alter ego is fritz
so free fritz for franklin it's a
it's a freach now basically i don't
believe that and what i think happened
is that just in the same way that wonder
and vision ended up going back in the
house after shiro one time
that he likely ended up going back
through the sewers there's also white
vision
and though it feels like we should have
got answers to what happened to him
jack schaefer the showrunner said
there's no scene of where white vision
is in the world because the point is
that he's not her
guy that's not the man that she had
children with that's not the one who's
been in the sitcom world with him
that's not the one that she said goodbye
to on a hill in wakanda
that's the body and the data so the
purpose of me
and my job on the show and what i focus
on where he ends up is an
afterthought to the story proper so he
is out there still
and will likely be popping up in a
property down the line personally i
think he went to wakanda
but we do know that he'll be back
potentially to stop wonder going off the
deep end
anyway that's the video and i hope you
enjoyed us clearing up some things and
giving possibilities for the other
things that we didn't get clarity on
if you request elaboration then the
comments are the perfect place to go
as i'm sure someone much smarter than me
will have an answer for you
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
show on the 31st of march in which we're
giving away three copies of a marvel 4k
box set of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the series and
just questions in general the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our brighton up why
justice league sucks which will be
linked on screen right now
we've gone over the movie top to bottom
got got a little bit drunk whilst doing
it
and just ripped it apart if not though
hopefully i see you
see you soon mates and uh take care i
mean paul
goodbye what do you say anyways i don't
care i'll see you next time